when you read that tweet you know what
the White House released that was
released
July 21st which is what five days ago I
think today's the 26th make make it
bigger so they can see it just click on
the no just click on yeah click on that
zoom out a little bit okay watch that
so uh uh what is a recession while some
maintain that two consecutive quarters
of Fallen real GDP constitute a
recession that is neither the official
definition nor the way economists
evaluate the state of the business cycle
instead both official determinations of
recessions and economists assessment of
economic activity are based on holistic
look at the data including the labor
market consumer on business spending
industrial production incomes based on
these data it is unlikely that the
decline in GDP in the first quarter of
this year even this is the key word here
this is the key word this is this is
protecting to say they're about to
announce that there was a decline in the
GDP second quarter watch out and ends up
even if it followed
by an even if followed by another GDP
decline in second quarter indicates a
recession now if this isn't trying to
redefine a recession pre-mid terms I
don't know what it is Tom what do you
think about this you know it's just I I
think they're testing our limits to just
how stupid yeah you know we we think we
are they are it's it's just not working
anymore in order to sell this you need
other than very creative writers and
they have some I mean I give them credit
for trying this spin
but the realities are out there
everybody's dealing this with this on a
daily basis and there's no credibility
coming back from the White House anymore
like you would believe them if they said
that we all know the situation right now
um it's just I think they spend so much
time ignoring the real issues not
finding ways to fix problems that they
start believing it themselves and every
day if there's something new that
they're trying to brainwash us with and
news flash we're just not that stupid I
think collectively people are waking up
yeah for me it's more like a it's white
house it's like clout over country where
all they care about is the the feel good
virtue signaling stuff as this watch
economic collapse happen and then I mean
to your to the point there I mean
they're they're making excuses already
and they're lying well and they know
it's coming they know that report is
going to become just you're like that's
like saying just because this tastes
like water and the second sip tastes
like water it's not water yeah like and
we're smarter than you you have to
believe us yeah that's not why that's
not water yeah because we make all the
definitions you don't we're Adam would
we trust them anymore like come on like
over
the pandemic yeah and they're coming in
here does anybody believe this that's
the point though that's that I think
that's the main question because what's
the approval rating what approval rating
just came out I I saw something because
I know Adam always talks about the as
bad as his approval rating is it's not
lower than Trump
it might be worse now yeah his approval
rate I think is the lowest like all-time
low well beating beating out Trump so if
I'm correct though the Trump's approval
rating was like at the end of his term
right it was at the very yeah during
covet yeah and then after the January
stuff but this is like this is now you
know not even two years into it Adam
what do you think when you hear this
kind of uh you know well I think the
narrative the the GDP uh report is
supposed to come out on Thursday I
believe and I don't believe that there's
going to be a pretty picture inside so
right there now they're trying to do a
spin job they have uh what's a new press
secretary Kareem Saint Pierre she's out
there sort of doing like mental
wrestling trying to redefine what a
recession is but
whether they come out and say it's a
recession or not I think Americans feel
what's going on right with inflation
with surging home prices people feel it
so uh they're gonna look whether it's
Republican or Democrat nobody wants to
own that you have yeah we have it you
know congratulations you're gonna try to
do a spin job but at the end of the day
the voters are going to have you know
their opportunity to say what's on their
mind this November in the midterms and
we'll see what happens but
clearly economically it's not a pretty
sight in America right now we talked
about the FED doing the quantitative
tightening right now so they're saying
that inflation is what it reached 9.1
percent in June they're starting to say
that it's coming down they're starting
to say that gas prices are coming down
and whether you're a Democrat or
Republican I think we are on the same
page we want prices to go down we want
inflation to go down we don't want a
shitty economy so we'll see what kind of
spin job they do but uh for the sake of
the country I'd like to see us not in a
recession but like you talked about on
your housing uh real estate housing
segment you did recently I think the
what my fear is it is the worst still
upon us like if this is the worst of the
worst right now I think Americans have
dealt with it is the worst is something
worse coming I think that's the question
right now so I'm going to read this from
an economist if you can pull this one up
because this is all over the place uh
here's an economist his name is uh
noriel rubini team just so you know who
noriel rubinius is an Iranian American
Economist he teaches at NYU
Stern School of Business and chairman of
rubini macro Associates so this is not a
regular guy he got his degree from
Harvard and uh he's done very well for
himself he also went to Hebrew
University of Jerusalem I know you would
appreciate that so so Economist a
shallow recession uh calls are totally
delusional rubini warrants this is a
Bloomberg article he said the U.S is
facing a deep recession as interest
rates rise and the economy is burdened
by high debt uh loads calling those
expecting a shallow downturn delusional
there are many reasons why we are going
to have a severe recession and a Severe
debt and financial crisis the chairman
and chief executive of macro Associates
said on Bloomberg TV on Monday the idea
that this is going to be short and
shallow is totally delusional look you
got two sides you pick and choose who
you want to believe so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here